anything exciting happen at the hub I
shot a superior officer in the chest hey
youtubers it's Charlie this week on
agents of shield we got a big guest star
Victoria hand from the MCU the science
team took the lead again and we got some
more backstory on sky so let's talk
about her favorite moments and then I'll
do my review first off Simmons spycraft
and Simmons sandwich craft she is the
true genius of this episode since these
guys are the science team they basically
get most of the comedic roles and they
were totally up to the challenge in this
episode next up Coulson versus Victoria
hand if you're not familiar with the
character from the MCU she rose to power
during Norman Osborn's tour at the head
of shield
or whenever became hammer he's loyal to
Nick Fury and shield but you can kind of
think of her as like an evil version of
Cobie Smulders Maria hill like I said
during the episode several times trust
the system they said it so many times it
basically lets you know that you're not
supposed to trust the system it's part
of the Winter Soldier plot but this
stratification of information and these
levels seven eight I'm sure all the way
up to ten basically make it so that
people can get away with things and
everyone else won't find out by the time
we get to Winter Soldier in the spring
that basically will be the plot will be
kept in America and Nick Fury trying to
get rid of that element inside of shield
but without that culture of secrecy we
would not have had that Simmons spycraft
moment that was so amazing I am totally
hoping that Simmons gets to go on more
field missions in the future I learned a
little bit more about her backstory but
not at the expense of Ward and Fitz so I
think she really is back on Team Coulson
I think a lot of people wondered about
her loyalty after she betrayed the team
in that previous episode but moments
like this where she basically stops and
thinks of others before herself really
let you know that she does care about
all these people but on all of my
favorite moments were Fitz and Simmons
moments I tend to think more of the
comedic and you know character
interaction moments than I do of the
action sequences there were a few
ridiculous action sequences I'll talk
about during my review that I didn't
really care for but the really big
question after this episode who is going
to post that pesto sandwich recipe
online it would not be a Marvel show
though if they did not reference big
things from the MCU so Black Widow
Hawkeye and the Triskelion got big name
drops during the episode hopefully we
will see the Triskelion during Captain
America the Winter Soldier just because
it's such an epic thing that it would be
way too expensive to show during a TV
show but I don't think we will be sick
Hawkeye or Black Widow on agents field
anytime soon either in reference to
Skye's backstory because we saw that
dead woman in that final picture I think
that that was actually Skye's mother
that means that her father could
actually be a villain so I'm guessing
that SHIELD agent that dropped her off
was actually sent to kill them on a
mission the jury's still out on the true
identity of her parents but remember
that date 1989 that was what she was
looking at so think about big Marvel
villains that were active in the comic
books during 1989 speaking of other big
references the big Thor crossover is
next week that episode is going to be
directed by Jonathan Frakes from Star
Trek The Next Generation so I am totally
hoping for some hilarious Star Trek
references
you should have subscribe to get my
video I think some of the complaints
against the show in the first couple of
episodes were is that it was kind of
avoiding a lot of integration with a
larger MCU either because it was trying
to sell itself apart or I just didn't
want to get too bogged down and a lot of
the Canon but I think they listened to a
lot of notes so I think we will start
seeing a lot more references to larger
things going on in the MCU from now on
out well what did I think of the episode
overall I rated to be I am totally
loving Fitz and Simmons right now they
are my favorite characters on the show
after Coulson in May compared to them
Ward and Skye really just seemed like
the most boring characters ever so I'm
really hoping that changes the next
couple of episodes because those two
characters just don't feel like they
have the backstory or the relationship
that Fitz and Simmons have one of my few
complaints against the episode was that
the jet rescue at the end was just a
little too over-the-top it was just a
little too ridiculous using the jet
stream to blow characters around on
screen but like I said I really did like
that they're starting to work in Marvel
movie Marvel MCU plots into the show but
forget about that Winter Soldier plot
for now because next week the Thunder is
coming I don't think we'll be having a
Thor cameo but the story will work with
the story from Thor the dark world so
it'll be a lot of fun
don't forget I'm also doing a bunch of
special Doctor Who programming this week
right now you can click here to find out
about that and you can click here to
learn all about agents of shield this
season thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow high fives
you